[Music]
ladies and gentlemen first I'd like to
thank you for watching and listening
this is the first time I've done
anything like this so if I appear a
little awkward I hope you'll forgive me
and since I've written notes for this I
shall be looking away some of the time
and I hope it doesn't make me look too
shifty
I'm not shifty I'm looking at my notes
and it's very unusual for me to address
an audience like this normally I can see
people who are falling asleep in the
front row but take that as a warning but
on this occasion I can't anyway crime
and punishment of course is a is a
subject of eternal interest insofar as
anything in the human is eternal and the
great French sociologist Durkheim
thought that crime and criminals
performed a useful social function
because they United the rest of society
against them and some kind of unity is
essential for for any society
unfortunately this view even if correct
doesn't quite tell us how many criminals
and necessary to perform this function
and my view is that we have more than
sufficiency to do this of course both
the concepts of crime and punishment are
happy hunting-grounds
for philosophers of whom I am NOT one
for example crime is not a natural
category as say is as species of insect
so what is criminal in one country may
not be criminal in another obvious
example is the age of consent to sexual
relations which vary from country to
country
so what is a crime in one what an axe
that is a crime and one country is not
necessary a crime in another than this
perfectly legal in fact note however
that few people would deny that there
should be an age of consent
there must be an age of consent to
sexual relations and the fact is that
most societies do not permit you to hit
a passerby and take his possessions so
in fact for many things we know
perfectly well war crime is its and I
don't propose to go any further in
refutation of the radical skepticism one
sometimes and meets on this question and
of course the concept of punishment has
likewise been the object of a great deal
of philosophical skepticism
philosophical attacks on punishment as a
practice have been very frequent but I
do not think that any society at least
no society known to me has been able
quite to do without it whatever
philosophers say the philosophers may
deny that punishment serves any of its
supposed functions such as deterrence
reform protection of the public and as
to retribution or the expression of
social disapproval of the perpetrators
there has often been said to be it has
often been said to be discreditable
retribution is merely nasty and those
who believe in it should be well I won't
say punished but at least reprehended so
that they should be actually persuaded
that their view is wrong and primitive
well I've observed as a matter of
empirical fact that people phenological
extreme liberals who believe that there
should be no such response to crime as
punishment
or the punishment should be lenient and
resemble a kind of rectification of the
scope of the soul or moral physiotherapy
usually retain in their hearts one
particular crime the rape or child abuse
or fraud that should be harshly
repressed by what can only be called
punishment in those cases no one doubts
the necessity of punishment
therefore punishment is like nature that
you throw it out with a pitchfork yet it
will return in this case to the human
mind one of the philosophical currents
that seems opposed to the notion of
punishment is determinism there are
different types of determinism of course
that which is merely metaphysical and
starts from the premise that since
everything is cause there is no such
thing as freedom of will and if there is
no freedom of will there can be no such
thing as guilt or desert and therefore
punishment is unjustified and there is
of course also economic sociological
psychological neuropsychiatric
determinism each of which claims
completely or at least satisfactorily to
explain Ann's behavior that took himself
there all point to the same conclusion
has the metaphysical variety of
determinism namely that there is no
justification for punishment of crime or
and neither than anything else it seems
to me however such determinism if our
going as it needs to be if it is of
philosophical interest or in if it's
going to be philosophically compelling
in any way leaves everything as it was
because those who punish are a subject
determinism or determination that
deterministic forces as are the punished
if he if someone sentences the criminal
or rather
the person who comes before the court
because of criminality does actually
imply and imply freedom of will in most
legal systems because if there's no
intent commits a crime there is no crime
in those cases if if the person the
person sentencing decides for example
that the criminal should be hanged drawn
and quartered he is as much determined
as is the criminal I am NOT a meta
physician but I don't think there is
anyone who's actually able to think of
himself in this way even when special
pleading on his own behalf no one
actually believes that he is determined
in the way I've just described even the
most determined determined determinist
if anime support it makes an exception
in his own case and usually for his for
his parents also because most people do
not fail to blame their parents for
things that they didn't like during
their childhood he experiences choice
every hour of his working life if not
with his waking life I should say if not
more frequently than that he therefore
implicitly divides humanity into two
those who can't help they do and himself
he is in a completely different category
for him he is an object for himself he
is the subject but everyone else is an
object a determined object now of course
I haven't actually met anyone who is
really like this most people are divided
humanity more subtly than than this that
is to say into the kind of first person
who can be held responsible for his
actions and the kind of person who
cannot generally speaking such people
pride themselves on the
generosity of spirit in a way that the
divine humanity and of course in certain
circumstances they are right to do so
perhaps I can illustrate what I mean by
a simple clinical case a very old man in
the hospital and I use to work became
confused and paranoid and in his fear of
imaginary enemies he pushed a very heavy
meal probably done the ward and in so
doing injured someone quite badly now it
was discovered that there was a
derangement in his biochemistry
instantly he had never done anything
like this before in his life it was
discovered that there was something
wrong there was a derangement in his
chemistry in the blood chemicals which
had caused him to become confused and
paranoid now of course there's no final
explanation of anything unless you
believe in the internet progress that is
an argument for the existence of God and
there must have been of course a cause
of his disordered blood chemistry but
for most explanatory purposes and this
deranged meant was sufficient to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a IDOT TV for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
you